[Musica]
donne per strada nasce perché ce n'era
bisogno e non lo sapevamo non lo
sapevamo nemmeno noi non sapevamo quante
donne non dicessero non hanno mai detto
a nessuno
quanta paura anno in strada quanta paura
a casa e quante storie hanno da
raccontare donne per strada nasce in
modo spontaneo e in un modo altrettanto
spontaneo si ingrandisce diventa un
movimento enorme pieno di donne
che partecipano perché vogliono fare
qualcosa contro violenza di genere ad
oggi h24
noi possiamo accompagnare le donne non
solo a casa possiamo fare compagnia di
giorno e di notte su istiga
basta appunto scrivere ss diretta e noi
abbiamo in un minuto
la nostra diretta la nostra
videochiamata di accompagnamento e
stiamo con loro con queste persone per
tutto il tempo quindi dieci minuti venti
minuti mezz'ora e parliamo e loro ci
dicono mi sento più sicura mi ha
cambiato e cambiato il percorso noi
chiamiamo la polizia se succede qualcosa
e noi video registriamo la chiamata in
modo tale che se c'è una denuncia perché
bisogna denunciare ma è difficile
noi offriamo la nostra video
testimonianza che può cambiare una
sentenza con donne per strada
riusciamo ad arrivare anche in quella
casa dove non arriva questa informazione
dove non arriva questo sguardo dove non
arriva la persona che ti dice questo non
è normale
questa persona non ti tratta bene per
strada non meriti di sentirti osservata
sporca seguita di essere seguita di
avere paura perché non abbiamo paura a
caso perché è una donna può morire in
strada oa casa è la realtà per me era
normale
camminare da sola per strada
era normale tornare a casa alle 5 di
notte e vedermi un quartiere da sola
passeggiare con il telefono scarico
nessuno sapeva dove ero la mia famiglia
era lontana nessun amico o amica
avvertita non ci hanno detto che
che dobbiamo lottare per una cosa che
dovrebbe essere normale che è ridicolo
dover lottare non abbiamo scelto di fare
questo di occuparci di violenza non
vorremmo vorremmo fare altro vorremmo
parlare della bellezza va il brutto
esiste e questa è la realtà e deve esser
vista solo adesso capisco che non ero
strana io ma che ha tante altre donne è
successo questo forse adesso lo posso
dire perché adesso con voi mi sento al
sicuro adesso con voi siamo insieme
siamo sempre insieme la nostra voce e la
voce di ognuna la storia di ognuna che
non è mai creduta e ascoltata da noi e
speriamo di ascoltarne tante speriamo
che un giorno queste storie non saranno
più queste ma saranno storie belle star
e di unione storia di di autostima di
forza di amore
speriamo appunto di non dover più
esistere perché se esistiamo oggi perché
era necessario
perché vogliamo essere libere e non
coraggiosa
[Musica]